i remember when whata dropped the first
shot of caesar and everybody's like
that's not a real chimpanzee all of the
pillars here all the walls they're all
built with a very very specific
algorithm and math
man so many suits so many suits so many
thrusters oh that's cool
oh yeah this is my shot oh yeah no no
way this is like an iconic shot this is
a big big shot
hey welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artists react we have a
treat today we are joined by sean walker
from what uh effects that's right he
flew all the way across the ocean just
being our show sean can you tell us a
little bit about yourself what kind of
what have you worked on what do you do
i'm a wedder's digital effects
supervisor i've done a few films in fact
i've done every marvel film that wetter
itself has worked on at least that has
been released aside from maternals
so i've been pretty keen to be involved
in everything marvel uh whenever
something came along sweet well let's
jump into some clips and you can break
down some of the cool stuff that you've
had to do
oh he's a smart one isn't he so we
haven't actually taken a look at any of
the planet of the apes films yet i've
been holding off because i've been
really wanting to do some like deep dive
research into it and then do an entire
themed episode around the trilogy but
having you here seems like a much better
opportunity to talk about it
no
i remember when whata dropped the first
shot of caesar and everybody's like
that's not a real chimpanzee there's a
pretty landmark moment for visual
effects and you know perhaps a signifier
of like where they were going to be
moving to like in this decade you know
kind of like that last little bit of
like we're still on the verge of like
the cg lighting's not quite a full
accurate representation of how physics
actually work with light but it's really
close to something like and we're there
yeah
i feel like the chimpanzees from planet
of the apes is a master class in
leveled simulations i guess because you
can't just like animate a character's
bones and then render it you know you
got all the layers of muscle and skin
and then hair all of those things have
to happen in order to have a realistic
looking animal exactly you can't have
stiff skin and then just have the the
fur simulate as a separate element
everything is layered it all needs the
simulation underneath to make the
simulation on top work
so this was my main sequence on this
show as well this was pretty crazy lots
of reflections lots of cg monkeys oh my
god
reflections
on all the cars reflections before yeah
it's a thing
[Laughter]
were you a lighting lead on this project
or what was your role on this project
specifically yeah i think i was a
lighting lead on this one so all of
these digital creatures running around
on an environment every car had to be
modeled and we had to render all the
reflections and all of that geometry
very tricky but uh necessary i mean
you'll notice if you had someone else
running around in the reflections it's
one of those things it's like it's so
annoying i can't see any circus you have
to do it if you don't add it people will
notice but if you do add it people don't
notice
that's exactly right yeah this bridge
was extraordinarily heavy as well i
think every bolt was just modelled and
it was so overly detailed and we barely
see them oh yeah that's right because
the bridge is obviously a cg bridge
because you're not on
the golden gate bridge yeah i imagine
the cars on the ground are real so a
good chunk of the map but then beyond a
certain point they're all cg yeah what
were some of the considerations you had
to have for a sequence like this with
all of the chimpanzees and parts of a
real set and a lot of the set being
digital what would you say was the
largest consideration that you had to
take for the most part it was just
dealing with all the interaction there's
just so much that goes on in a sequence
like this for every character or actor
that these creatures interacted with you
always had to match move and make sure
that you had those beautiful shadows
that played off them as well same with
bounce light you always want to make
sure that if a character is obscuring
someone in the plates then you want to
make sure that that's obscured uh
properly as well and then just yeah the
enormous amount of reflective material
in the scene was uh something you just
had to deal with
[Music]
so dawn of the planet apes this is the
second movie and i remember there being
a really cool sort of innovation on this
movie which was onset motion capture and
you didn't have to like redo any of that
stuff in a studio yes exactly for the
most part i think we called it
performance capture and we did go back
to the studio occasionally to do some
motion capture i mean that's fair yeah
but uh it helps in so many different
ways one your actors are working in the
environment that they should be and
they're reacting to their environment
which i think is incredibly important
and we also got perfect lighting data to
work with you know if you're in a studio
you don't see the light react to the
performances in the actual environment
and on the set so i think that's another
good reason why we were able to get
such you know beautiful shots in the end
oh yeah this is my shot oh yeah no no
way i live and rendered this yeah
this is like an iconic shot
this is a big big shot
this was tricky as hell and it was the
first movie that we started to use
manuka which is our path tracer that we
built from the ground up and to get this
level of detail with the tools that we
had at the time was very tricky these
are huge projects so the amount of
people we had working on them was insane
this was at a time when almost the
entire facility would be working on
individual projects so
yeah a lot of people worked on these
ones my impression of plan of the apes
was this is kind of wet as demonstration
of everything they've learned with
character animation from lord of the
rings and then as they like branched out
with a king kong to them bring it all
together now in something that's not
lord of the rings you know it's not king
kong it's brand new and let's show the
world that we can redefine digital
effects i i felt that too when we were
even working on it i knew that this was
something special rise was kind of that
stepping stone and then when we had dawn
i just knew that this is sort of
pinnacle effects i mean having worked on
these these shots still blow my mind i
think the assets were unbelievable to
work with the story and the lighting and
the end result still blows my mind even
when i come back to watching them years
later i was very disappointed that it
didn't
win the oscars i think
all three of them were robbed
yeah i remember when war for the planet
of the apes was going to the oscars i
distinctly remember being like it's
going to win and then when it didn't i
was like what
what
i was blown away anyway
so iron man 3 was a movie that you
worked on as well and this movie was
notable in the iron man trilogy for
having just a ton of different suits
yeah
and so many suits so many suits so many
thrusters
so we had
what did we end up with or maybe 40 odd
suits they're all very unique our team
had to develop ways of handling them all
so all of this thruster work all of the
lasers that they were shooting was
pretty much automated at a certain point
animation would drive the look of all
the shots and then we set up systems
that would just replicate what they did
but make it look better they shot a lot
of this on set so this environment
actually existed but we did go fully
digital quite a few times
that was an actual practical effect as
well of him like smashing through wait
really yeah yeah so there was some real
explosions there yeah there was a lot of
real explosions here those containers
getting flipped up all practical we just
put a igor in here
igor is the name of this particular one
and they all had their own names it was
pretty funny they you know they were
pretty classic
so this guy you see him jumping off that
guy who jumps off was literally an
actual stunts person who jumped off this
insanely high thing and then we had to
get rid of him because he jumped onto a
digital iron man and it ended up this
beautiful stunt uh had to go away and we
would have just i mean that is a brave
person yeah it was literally like a
bungee jump so wow which was a little
bit sad but that's the kind of thing
that just happens every once in a while
again beautiful reference that's what we
end up with
that's true reference is super important
[Music]
dude his arm broke yeah that's
definitely a digital arm this extremist
effect is something that we're pretty
much call the extremist effect from now
on like whenever there's glowing
interior bodies it's a very unique look
because you know skin is slightly
transparent if you shine a light through
it it kind of glows and so that's why
you end up with a little bit of like
that red sort of glow but it's a whole
different monster when you're having
light inside of like an object like that
emitting light and it's now glowing from
within yeah we actually built this up in
so many different layers we have little
volume lights and little point lights
that are lighting up killian's interior
here and then the veins would occlude
the light and same with the skeleton so
i'm assuming it's a full body
replacement right yes and no some of it
was but we wanted the tattoos to include
the light so we wanted the tattoos to be
real we wanted the skin to be real so we
kept almost all of that and the rest of
this is actually just passes on top and
multiple different layers that we use to
augment the actual plate rather than
replace them entirely so you're seeing a
lot of that sort of glow where you can
kind of see like the muscle on his arm
and the veins and whatnot are you saying
those are 2d passes on top yes okay
exactly okay and then someone had to
roto all of the tattoos and make sure
that those passes were occluded by the
tattoos
so all of this stuff here guy ps was on
new shows he had half a beard and they
thought it might help if they just glued
his beard down to his face
wait
so that you're saying this was a pickup
but he was already on another project
this is like superman's mustache yeah
kind of a scenario here very much yeah
and they're like all right we're gonna
have to paint out this beard yeah so
it'll help if we just make the outline
of the beard smaller by gluing it to his
face yeah yeah oh you know what that's
actually kind of clever did it help no
he's an entirely digital character
really yeah 100
wow
at a certain point it kind of just makes
more sense to do it that way especially
for like that moment there where he's
like entirely falling apart crumbling on
fire man the stuff that comes off him i
think this is a beautiful effect the
skin that yeah that cools and fractures
and then peels off i think yeah it's
it's amazing yeah i really dig it man i
can't imagine building a digital human
of that quality and of that caliber for
like five shots yeah exactly it's very
insane yeah i thought guy pierce's
character here looked extremely well
done yeah for the time as well yeah what
year did this come out was this 2013 yep
you know it's weird to think of a movie
like iron man 3 being almost a decade
old yes
yeah christian is like
well
when i'm looking for stuff to react to i
go to the comments section of each video
so leave a comment to help me out for
the next one
please
i've not yet seen black widow so you're
gonna get raw reactions to me right here
great i actually haven't seen it either
this is our sort of like super large
effects task for the show i love the
rendering of the avalanche everything is
always perfectly backlit and the light's
going through it just in the right way
we studied a lot of real-life avalanches
to make sure that we were you know
accurate to the light penetration into
an avalanche and snow it's a lot softer
than you would anticipate so this is a
little bit more dense than i think would
be real but we needed that weight to be
able to justify the explosions and the
destruction that goes on as well so it's
probably a little bit more
snow chunky heavy than everything else
yeah that's so good
so what's an avalanche do you simulate
it as a fluid sim or a rigid body sim
with a bunch of particles is it a liquid
or smoke type deal it's a bit of
everything uh to be honest so the
baseline of the simulation was also in
houdini where that would describe the
overall shape and that would be made out
of a little bit more of a solid volume
from that we simulated using synapse a
much much larger volume in fact this
whole thing was essentially one take one
cache oh really
wow dang so there's literally a master
file of just like this whole avalanche
wiping out this facility that you can
just like
yeah we should we should real quick we
should clarify for the viewers why
it's cool that this is all one take so
the avalanche you're explaining is the
entire thing
off the mountains through the field into
this area just one super long super good
detail
yeah go and they walked away for like
what like three months and then came
back
but the reason we did it is because we
wanted the flexibility at the end of the
day to alter the timing because they
were cutting things in and out and uh
you know if you you take away a shot all
of a sudden the avalanche isn't in the
right place at the right time so all
that stuff in the background it's all
just one giant simulation that we were
able to you know reverse and forward
wherever we needed to match the
composition of the shot i guess it also
makes sense that you'd need to do it in
one simulation too because you need all
the like the remnants of the avalanche
yep so let's say it's like okay we need
a shot that's like you know 30 seconds
after the avalanche happened it's like
you need all that lingering snow and
something like sure you can go in there
you can start doing it by hand and put
it on there but well how do you get that
there well you just you simulate it yeah
exactly yep
oh that's cool
that's the promise of uh simulations
right there so you can do stuff like
that because back in the day you'd have
to film it as a real element but you
could have that kind of interaction with
it no the one thing is that you always
need you know simulation is hard but
there are just some things you just
can't do without a really good effect
simulation artist so i'm not quite
convinced it's not just like real steam
how do you guys film
there's some liquidity proud of that
yeah it looks pretty great i do agree so
there's one thing i've wanted in life
it's a diamond play button you get it
for having 10 million subscribers on
youtube well we are only 4.55 million
subscribers away so help us out
consider subscribing
i hope you're ready it'll be here any
minute
so what'd you guys have to do with
guardians of the galaxy we focused
primarily on the third act battle but we
did have a few shots here and there
beforehand some of the eclectic shots
and the mutiny and ejecting all of some
of the soldiers out into space and then
we start here for our third eight battle
part i call it
the expansion the big thing throughout
production of all of volume two was
fractals we had this shared asset with
animal logic i believe built it and this
one was quite tricky so all of the
pillars here all the walls they're all
built with a very very specific
algorithm and math to generate a
specific look because fractals can be
quite random depending on how you
generate it we had to match exactly what
animal logic did here so they saved
everything out as points in space it
wasn't even geometry it was just uh
particles wow point clouds yeah exactly
there's a point cloud so almost this
entire wall and pillars were built just
out of point clouds wow because just how
the fracture generates it yeah so are we
literally looking at a point cloud
render or did that get sort of like
geometry eyes at some point for animal
logic i wouldn't be surprised if they
did it as a point cloud render for us we
geometrized okay
that's what this word gmti exactly
i guess volumize like volume building
yeah meshing
yeah
that's the word i'm looking for
you killed my mother i tried
so hard
to find the form
i forgot about that completely
sir
it was a very sort of rough delivery and
we had to there's a lot of projection
work done here together to work and
yeah there's a lot of manipulation to
try and get that plate to work so you
guys will build a 3d model reproject the
footage onto the 3d model and then do
that to be able to re-light it and try
to make the lighting look
different that was almost entirely done
with grades though as opposed to 3d
re-lighting so those are the very very
different looking plays
okay i was actually going to compliment
the actors for being like wow they
actually managed to like do the exact
same performance spot on whoever like
directed them to do that great job and
now i'm looking at the plates i'm like
it's not remotely the same
they're looking like completely opposite
direction
and yet because i guess you're able to
project the geometry onto that and
reorient it you were able to get them to
match but wow i'm now realizing that was
a lot more work than i initially
envisioned yeah that was tough that was
very it's very tough
[Music]
this is one of our favorite shots i
think we had a few people that wanted to
do this
[Laughter]
[Music]
so this whole planet has like an
internal structure to it that you guys
had to create for this movie yep all of
that internal structure is based off
that original algorithm that we got and
then we artistically started to pull
pieces out skew it and bend it into
place oh how dense these models are this
environment was insane like it was so
big i think a good chunk of these shots
probably could have been done in a much
cheaper way but
in saying that doing things the more i
guess expensive way meant that we could
shoot this thing from any angle we
wanted so we knew that when we were
going into it we could give james gunn
the opportunity to position the camera
anywhere in the scene and it would just
work so after actually generating these
pillows and everything every pillar has
been dressed with the tiniest of i guess
you would call it fungi like they could
have resembled fungi yeah just all this
additional detail was dressed on top by
our layout department and they just
scattered all of this additional
geometric detail on top of all the base
that has all the holes and the practical
detail you know all these cool little
bits of design how much of that
creativity is directed and given to you
or i was like i want this exactly and
how much of that is left up to you guys
just come up with cool ideas it's a
little bit of both to be honest we will
oftentimes get some previews done by
another vendor for marvel they like to
work with a company called third floor
and they produce so much work like i
think there's just so much going on
right now that they're having to source
from other companies and we'll match the
shots but sometimes they'll say you know
this shot could be a little bit better
if it was done this way or that way and
will alter to suit yeah especially
something like this that has very unique
and specific art direction it's hard to
know whether or not it's working until
you're at a certain point in the process
yeah that's exactly right when they're
shooting things they have no idea that i
mean
that's gonna happen
big lightning face yeah with a huge
rolling ball of energy it's all kind of
on the fly yes i mean not all but you
know it very much gets to that point at
certain times okay we got a little nerdy
and detailed about that sequence there
so i think most of that's probably going
to end up on the website so make sure
you're subscribed to quarterdigital.com
to see us go into some pretty granular
detail about that whole sequence there's
a free trial
no skin off the backs no skin attacks no
skin attacks
it's always crazy to actually
study the visual effects from the people
who created them so sean thank you so
much for joining us today it was a huge
honor to have you here i wish you the
best at the oscars this weekend by the
time this episode comes out all the news
around the oscars will be out but you'll
be there witnessing it in real time
oh wow and i'm a little jealous
that was a
greatest night in the history of
television so that's going to be really
awesome but more than that thank you for
being here yeah i really appreciate it
it's a pleasure to be here it's been
awesome i do watch you guys a lot so
it's it's pretty crazy sitting here on
this green couch
it's amazing thank you i appreciate the
time no thank you
thank you